news championship and it was uh priya
master priya
was helping me in this tournament
e4 played by uh ezipenko
all right let's see the italian is
back on good yeah 1963
okay d6
castle this is all very normal
it's been cursor s3 okay that's a
typical
uh position obviously yes
it's also very important not to play h3
too quickly here and then always
like we'll go h5 h6 g5 yeah exactly
sorry sante thank you
at this way not something
something is when you have a drink i
think exactly
yeah i know uh to yeah
the hoya was not all that all yeah he
was
56 or something so yeah he died
two way too early of course
knight f1 okay and this is supposed to
be a bit better for white
okay yeah many games were here
yes 56 are you so booked
booked here i'm booked here
yeah i know it's kind of uh one of the
starting position and okay of course
white has more space
and so on but it always feels like in
the
in the drawing zone let's say during
margin but
it's more pleasant so you go c6 knight
g6
okay eight that's of course a very
balanced position
a bit more pleasant to play for white
yes
it's long-term ideas but uh yes
although as as now black is actually
controlling the center yeah
so this bit yeah now black is very doing
well
that is basically the the kamikli
and he was still playing he was playing
always bishop a7 rookie eight bishop b6
and ty devising can play solid i think
there is a carlsen comic
game actually a long time no hs
in that line
so how why is normally contained here
yeah i5 is very logical
then you try to play c4 if you go d4 you
have knight d5 so after c4 you generally
go c6
and you don't give anything and
uh you just your knight on e3 is as well
a bit
better play than the knight on g6 that's
obvious
so yeah overall a bit more present i
don't know i would go c6 probably here
as black but
of course c5 also exists like bc and x8
if it works
you have some play here let's say
something like that
if it works it's nice for black actually
and if it doesn't work you're probably
lost yeah yeah
okay so you have to make sure it's
playing knight g6
after c4 i guess my bet is that he wants
c6
yeah and here you can see this knight on
this three is a bit better place than
the knight on g6 that's
very obvious but two in a must win
situation
to be honest i don't like kezie penco
choice
it's the position magnus knows he played
with white and with black he knows
exactly the ideas he knows as well that
of course it's a bit more present for
for white but it's okay for black so
i mean did he have a choice
is he pink yeah i mean you have the
choice not to play italian
to play something more yeah but okay
he's playing the italian
yeah okay always again and he just won
the game with the italian so
kind of logical to keep on playing yeah
that's tall actually
yeah magnus playing it's much more solid
than in the previous game
so of course you can take as well on c4
on d5 and play knight c4 that's always
an option
i would probably just go uh
d8 or f6 as well f6 d4 probably
yes so d8 and yeah
just hard to see what what's wrong here
no here it looks black is comfortable
but yeah
so c4 c6 and hook 81.
do you want to play something like d4
probably
like it is the default
holy is possible
very focused easy pencil no fear
trying to i'll play magnus in italian
you know that would be amazing
yeah i cannot say that i'm very excited
this match will go to armageddon but
okay
it is what it is yeah no it could
possibly very possibly
go to the american of course you can
always mistake
oh this is just c5 now yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's a thing
it's not easy to play moves here as
black actually i would probably consider
it a four
to make him a bit nervous about what i
can do
on the king side and knight f4 is played
by magnus but he has now one minute down
so you say edcd
d4 yeah but no okay e4
95
yeah maybe that's
because then this knight e3 of course is
a beast just stops all his mating ideas
huh
not only e5 stops all the rook moves to
g6
yeah and what else really
i don't see it that's a problem
that's kind of um what do you do i mean
if you don't go
plus that's what do you do you play
knight f5 okay
i was wondering if i could do d4 right
away but okay
that's past that's a little bit too much
probably as well
g6 played
giving up the pawn yeah but probably
it's going to switch for some attack
yeah
yeah just look e7 and oh good shades
yeah that was that is too dangerous
but if you come to f5 and you have to
come back then you lost the temple
yeah he's taking the pawn yeah this
looks oh boy
oh boy oh boy
this looks too dangerous huh way too
dangerous
okay eight good move taking g4
knight h2 will catch eight could be made
in a few moves actually yes and then g3
i think you just take on h2
yeah like it's two played okay it will
just try to hide your smile not at all
anyway people cannot see me you can only
see me ah okay
so i'm not adding anything
um
okay g is coming next yeah is coming
next exactly
taking only four take with the pawn i
guess
and queen is seven okay
you want to take a l you want queen h4
and after g3 i guess there's some nasty
stuff i don't see it
address 96.94 okay positional stuff
very very good conversations c5
yeah okay but uh wow come on
okay are you simply doubling him yeah i
know
[Music]
142 against 126. he's taking on the
eight
here comes um
quintex that's actually a question
g3 maybe
can you do that green
d4 check the h1
knight d3 that's the game that's that's
not good for
for magnus before i see penguin
didn't look very good but like this
where i would
ah my pawn might put my pawn king g2
what else can i do yeah but even some
infiltration like queen e3 or something
yeah
knight d3 is played
yeah the king king took queen e3 looks
looks
horrible okay
we need to play serve that
okay protecting against queen e3
i just taking the pawns here
knight f2 yes it looks
over to me i would agree with you it's
such a night
consenting active pieces
are more than fine with the physicians
we say fine torment by the ocean
youngster it's for the ocean
the russian youngster is more than that
i mean to come to the blitz against
magnus carson in a match
so mr barco rest in peace
who knows who knows who knows
this has been tough for magnus in the
last two two matches
[Music]
this attack shouldn't no work at all
taking pawns busy taking pawns
yeah okay of course he's trying to play
knight g4 and whatever
hoping for some check on the diagonal
but okay
well what's this he allowed this check
that was not the most precise way
to do it i guess especially because i
just announced it
but there's ninety four but yeah i mean
the king's yeah knight
knight four not like a six check
all right i'm losing what
no i thought i missed king h7
i know but still i think king hate was
probably also possible
yeah takes
check what else i mean he has to try
something yeah
such a lucky guy
lucky and good that's the right
combination
king g7 will come it couldn't be two
half queen c3 now
that's actually completely winning for
black
to for d2 even
not a bad move the clock 12 seconds
against 4 but doesn't really matter
just came over all the way
what do you play we don't have the moves
quick h4 queen oh finish [ __ ] g7f5
queen d5
f6 knight f6 what this is about
a check that's designed
i didn't see it was check okay
we see a smiling magnus
but it's been tough